hello everyone i'm alana and welcome to
my channel i made a video the day that
the
uh bethesda xbox acquisition news
dropped
um that i kind of wanted to follow up on
which just for anyone who somehow
doesn't know if you somehow missed this
news
basically this is a post on the xbox
newswire news.xbox.com
that says the critically acclaimed
creators of the elder scrolls fallout
wolfenstein doomed dishonored quake
staff little more will join team xbox
which is funny because it's technically
not true
bethesda didn't create some of these
franchises but in any case
basically microsoft has entered entered
into an agreement to acquire zenimax
media parent company of bethesda
softworks
meaning they ultimately own bethesda's
franchises
um like it says here these teams are
responsible for the elder scrolls
fallout wolfenstein doom dishonored
pretty quick starfield
and many more and when i initially made
a video about this
my immediate and forefront reaction is
generally always going to be the one
that i had because this is the way that
i think
um which is that this is very good for
accessibility uh it is great for the
disabled community
um to have access to every single
bethesda game
day one on game pass i mentioned in the
video before and have spoken about it in
other places
but ultimately the idea is that if you
are a gamer with a disability you'll
often have to spend 60 dollars here in
the us just to try a game find out an
hour later that you can't even play it
because there aren't
appropriate disability settings game
pass basically like alleviates all of
that and i
um try to celebrate that where i can i
do think it's it's very good for
uh lower income families and people in
other countries where the economy isn't
as strong as well too so
that's how i think most of the time but
i did also mention which has been um a
lot more hotly contested this week than
i
expected not just on my behalf but you
know this internet-wide
discussion of whether bethesda games
should be
exclusive uh for xbox and i think there
are a lot of interesting conversations
to be had around exclusivity
um and and this is both a lot more
simple
and a lot more nuanced than it may
initially seem
my stance is ultimately where this
particular deal is concerned that i
think it would
uh suck for a lot of people if a lot of
bethesda
titles that have traditionally been on
multiple platforms were
only xbox exclusive going forward your
fallout and your elder scrolls are
franchises that people are really deeply
invested in that are huge fans are
people with
tattoos you know those are massive
massive franchises uh doom 2 i suppose i
mean obviously wolfenstein is well
frankly it's
it's a lot of them and for those people
who've been invested in those franchises
their whole lives um i certainly think
of them
when it comes to the potential that if
they are playstation gamers
exclusively that they could miss out on
those franchises going forward
if they don't necessarily have the money
to buy into
another uh console or don't have a pc
um but still want to stick with
playstation i ultimately just think that
that is
like a huge bummer i would be surprised
if anyone disagreed with me on that
really but of course it's business
microsoft spent
4.7 billion dollars to acquire zany
zenimax that is
a tremendous amount of money that is
more money than disney spent to acquire
star wars it's absurd they can do
whatever they want i'm certainly not
telling microsoft that they can't
do whatever they want but there are
several reasons why this is being
discussed where it previously wasn't
discussed in the past
i've certainly seen a lot of internet
trash that's along the lines of like
well your sony bias is showing
why didn't you say this when sony
acquired insomniac uh why didn't you say
this
when sony acquired gorilla the reason i
didn't say it for sony is
layered but also really the same reason
i didn't say it when microsoft acquired
ninja theory or double fine it's because
they don't have those
long-running franchises that have always
been cross-platform so the this
conversation is quite separate where
bethesda is concerned it is a different
conversation
i do have major major criticisms of
sony uh making the push to have
spiderman
be playstation exclusive um where
uh marvel's avengers is concerned i
think that's a whole mess did not like
that one
at all did air that but generally
speaking the truth is that this is just
a different circumstance and it's a
circumstance where i do want to speak on
behalf of
both camps of gamers especially as
someone who owns both
consoles and will continue to own both
consoles it's also that microsoft
is more of a question mark we don't
generally know what microsoft will do
phil has
uh commented in the past phil spencer
head of xbox has commented in the past
negatively about
uh the current approach to exclusives
it's also that
after microsoft bought mojang and
minecraft they continued to have
minecraft on ps4 so it's
it's a conversation that's even worth
having my general stance
across the board is uh that i would
prefer that no company have exclusives
at all
um because i am a very accessibility
focused person i would prefer that all
gamers have access to all video games i
think that would be great but that's
simply not how business works and there
are a couple of reasons for that and i
do want to reiterate that i am speaking
generally because there are also
circumstances in which exclusives
elevate
video games where sony specifically is
concerned in the ps4 generation
yes on a high level i would prefer that
all of their exclusives were available
on every platform i am very happy that
uh horizon came to pc obviously death
stranding came to pc
i would like to see more of that going
forward uh however
there is a case to be made for what
exclusives do for the quality of video
games and this is something that i
wanted to talk about like solely with
the intent of trying to
be informative i'm not trying to sway
you either way i've laid out my stance
why bethesda is concerned which is that
microsoft can do whatever they want they
spend a lot of money of course it is
well within their rights to make these
games exclusive
i would think that probably what they
will do is actually keep them
multi-platform but for new ips like star
field potentially
have them be exclusive obviously they're
gonna be game past day one and that is a
selling point it means it's inherently
cheaper than everyone who has to buy
each of these games for 60 dollars on
playstation but they spend a lot of
money they can do whatever they want
yeah that's obviously the case i'm just
thinking on behalf of the people that i
feel kind of sad for that these are
being locked away after being
available to everyone for so long so
back to the exclusive conversation
particularly where sony is concerned
this generation with the playstation 4 i
think
that sony has made some of the best
games really ever um some absolute
gems uh that have been playstation
exclusive
i certainly think that that is the case
for bloodborne
i think that that is the case for god of
war and i also think that that is the
case for silent hill pt
which of course you know is a teaser
doesn't quite count but is
still one of my favorite horror
experiences ever in video games
there is a push for first party titles
man it also definitely is always the
case with nintendo for the record i feel
like it was the case for xbox lost
generation
i think gears 5 is fantastic i love sea
of thieves but i don't know that i would
put it in the same caliber as bloodborne
do also love the forza horizon series i
mean there are a lot of good exclusives
across the board but anyway
it contained to my point here when you
have exclusives
uh that are financially there
to sell you a console which is the case
from my understanding from what
developers have said sony really does
give their creative teams a lot of
freedom they do
let those developers make the games that
they want to make that is with trust in
those studios that is with those studios
hiring the right people and having
talented teams to make those studios so
thus they have faith in them
but the point is they do need them to be
of a particularly high quality
if those are the things that are making
people buy your hardware and get into
your ecosystem
exclusives basically have an extra
reason to be very good games
because they are trying to get you into
the playstation ecosystem so that you'll
get ps plus so you'll get ps now so you
will go on to those recurring
subscription services
so that every game that you buy they get
a 30 cut from the playstation store
you know if the exclusives are the
reason to be on playstation those
exclusives have to be
very good of course this applies to
everyone too but basically my point is
exclusives have to be a step above other
video games in a lot of cases
and because the exclusive landscape
exists it does mean we are getting
better video games in at least some
cases
that's not to say that third-party teams
aren't creative and aren't making good
stuff but there is
genuinely a much larger corporate
business incentive
to give you incredible um very well
polished
experiences that can also be
single-player and don't need micro
transactions or don't need to be games
service because their purpose is to get
you into the hardware the purpose is to
make you a playstation fan the purpose
is to get you on that thing
so exclusives in that case can be good
in that the quality of games that we're
getting is just generally higher
that also ties in to a game only needing
to be made for one platform
if you're only making it for one type of
hardware one type of architecture
then you can very much customize uh or
cater your
game to that hardware and have a much
smoother experience across the board
because you don't have to worry about a
million different
types of hardware or how is it going to
run on this how is it going to run on
that how is it going to run on pc
pcs obviously are minefields because
people can have such vastly different
pcs with such vastly different tech
i mean look at what happened to i
believe it was assassin's creed unity
that that bug with just one graphics
card where people's
eyes were the only thing that showed up
and their entire face disappeared
glad to have the memes but if that were
exclusive to one platform to the xbox or
to the playstation or to the nintendo
feels weird to say the nintendo doesn't
feel weird to say that xbox or the
playstation but saying the
nintendo feels very strange for some
reason basically
uh when you are very familiar with the
hardware that you're making a game on
when you know it is only being played on
that one thing with
almost no variance aside from obviously
your different pro units
in theory we could get better products
but yes i basically just wanted to
explore that where exclusives are
concerned in that that
they can correlate directly to extremely
high quality games but my main point
here was just i just wanted to discuss
exclusives how they work how they work
for business reasons and how they can
benefit us
while also generally being of the
mindset that i would prefer as many
people get to play games as possible
because
that is that is my my just the way that
i function as a human
i want everything to be nice for
everyone really
but yes to answer the question of like
why is it being asked
where microsoft is concerned where sony
doesn't get asked this question
about these bethesda games it is a
because we don't know what microsoft
will do
microsoft is much more of a question
mark where this is concerned um they did
say on a case-by-case basis
we know that if sony were to buy a
studio like bethesda or i suppose a
publisher like bethesda or zany max
that they would make their games
exclusive with microsoft it's more of a
question mark we don't know what they'll
do
there's also a case of them probably
actively knowing that there are more
players on playstation than there are
right now on xbox we don't know what's
gonna happen next gen but i imagine that
trend will continue in terms of sales
that they don't want to lose out on all
of those sales you could still sell a
million units of fallout on a
playstation 5
and microsoft will get that money but
yes ultimately
because we don't know it's worth asking
and i do really think that this
particular acquisition is different to
every other acquisition i i like i said
i didn't ask with ninja theory
i didn't ask with double fine i was like
i get it
with bethesda it just feels a little bit
different because i don't know
i care about the gamer you know
and these are franchises that people
love so much that um
it's just rough to to think about that
certain people who can't afford
both consoles will be locked out from
that and uh
yeah they can do whatever they want it's
a lot of goddamn money
i think it's maybe too much money for
them to just be doing it as a game pause
play
uh especially considering you know they
could have just done what they did with
ea
and uh figured out some kind of deal to
have bethesda games launch
on this service rather than sorry on
game pass specifically that is rather
than having to buy their entire studios
but
we don't know i also hope that the
employees don't get laid off
uh 2 300 people of course that's also
often a thing that happens when
a company is bought out that things are
sort of restructured from the sounds of
things the structure is going to say
basically the same i believe the board
is staying in place and all that good
stuff so maybe that won't happen
still a lot of question marks but yeah i
just really wanted to to explore this
one topic a little bit more
we don't know what's going to happen my
stance is generally i would prefer that
all of you have everything
um while also acknowledging that
sometimes exclusives result in
very very very high quality titles
it is not that black and white overall
and hey it sure is
uh sure is an eye-opener for a friendly
reminder of just how much money
microsoft has they really could just buy
it all if they wanted this isn't even
close to being a monopoly i said that in
my last video
um people were wondering about that on
twitter it's not even close
but certainly they could buy a lot of
people if they
really wanted to so just worth keeping
that in mind
all right you guys i feel like this was
a ramble just just some topics that i
wanted to explore
with you guys today i'm alana i'll see
you all next time bye